okay so my name is Sarah
Ellucian I'm a physicist I got the Nobel
Prize in 2012 and it was for the
manipulation of individual quantum
systems so what we did was to trap
photons in a box and manipulate and
control these photons which are the
grain of light to try to understand deep
properties of quantum systems and maybe
to find ways to use this for participa
to do something useful in the end and
the photon is at the same time a wave
and a particle they are very small and
it's a very difficult to isolate so they
are very elusive when you try to work
with them very easily destroyed the
photons are ubiquitous around us when
you look at something the photons enter
into your eye and then they are
destroyed so what we wanted to do is to
study the photons in a more general way
in a way which does not destroy them so
that we can keep studying them and learn
more about them as possible vehicle for
information the solution first was to
have a very good box a box which can
keep the photons bouncing inside for
very long times we were able to keep the
photons of about one tenth of a second
and then we sent atoms one by one
through the box and the atoms were just
picking some information from the
photons getting out and then we
interrogated the atoms towards and what
they had seen in the box so it's a
little bit the opposite in our case the
atoms were seeing the photons is really
the photons are the things which see the
object so we are reversing the problem
of seeing what would be the practical
application is another issue and we
don't know yet but people think that
there will be a new wave of quantum
technologies coming from the direct
exploitation of this strange quantum
properties then you would have to work
at the level of individual quantum
system
we all want
that our food is safe but doing that can
be really hard looking for contaminants
in raw materials is tough
the statistics are stacked against us
today we can only test for pathogens
individually one sample at a time and
that means hundreds is not thousands of
tests most of which deliver a simple
negative result we needed to think about
this differently
that's why Mars and IBM join forces to
sequence the genomes of all the
organisms in the food supply chain
that's millions of organisms but big
data is what IBM is good at the DNA and
RNA sequences show you all the harmless
bacteria that are found in normal safe
food if we do the test and the
microorganisms are suddenly different
something's up the organisms have
changed because the environment has
changed it could be contaminated and not
only that this tells us things that we
never could have seen before like where
the food was grown how it was
transported and maybe even what happened
on route our approach to food safety
just got a lot smarter